In the last two videos you learn to think
about the structure of language using
logic. I introduced using symbols for
constants and variables and how to break
statements into subject and predicate.
It's time to look at some logical symbols
that will give our sentences a bit
more structure.
Starting with quantifiers,
when we talk about a quantity,
we mean how many of something there are,
but ordinary language is fairly general,
even vague in its treatment of
quantity one house, two or more houses.
This is actually true of logic to,
we'll look at three basic quantities,
none.
Some,
which is one or more and all each
of these quantities is the symbol.
So we will have three symbols that
we can call quantifiers. First,
here's the quantifier all. Remember
when we use predicates with variables,
we ended up with sentences
like x is a person,
but this doesn't tell us
anything about that x.
Let's use x as a quantified
for any x.X is a person.
Let's try that with the sentence.
X saw why we get for any ex ex SAL.
Why one step further with
four MDX for any y x saw.
Why?
When I use any with these variables,
I'm really referring to all the
things x and y can stand for,
so let's throw the universal
quantify are all into the mix.
We get the sentence for all x.
X is a person in ordinary language.
You can read that as all of them are
people or just all people or all humans.
Let's look at another one for all eggs.
Jill saw x here.
We're basically saying
Jill saw everything,
but if we abandon these quantifiers and
just let the predicate we'd end up with
blank is a person and Jill saw Blake.
Okay,
let's move to another symbol.
This one is the existential quantified.
It acts like the universal quantifier.
All you just learned about,
but instead it means some or more
specifically there exists at least one.
Let's go back to our variable x.
In the phrase x is a person.
Let's say we wanted to talk about
some person. In other words,
for some x where x is a person will
need to use an existential quantified.
We'll also, you need to use it for
the sentence. Jill saw something.
Remember that Jill saw everything.
Use the universal quantify or all,
but for Jill saw something,
we'll use the quantify or some
our final quantifiers the symbol.
No.
Take a statement.
P This p might represent John
saw the movie or my house is red.
Then the negation of that statement,
not p would have the same form as John
didn't see the movie or my house isn't
red. I'm listening to ways of writing
the not symbol, but both have the same.
Take another statement this time with
an individual constant and a predicate.
As you saw in the last lesson, you can
write, John saw the movie this way.
Now let's turn the state same
statement into a negative.
John didn't see the movie.
See how that works.
Same goes for my house isn't red.
That's how a predicate is negated.
Same applies to the
predicates with variables.
X isn't a person x didn't see why,
but don't forget that you learned to
quantify or variables with all in.
Some take examples with a variable
like some person which I wrote as there
exists at least one x where x is a
person and all people or for all x,
x is a person. We can actually negate both
of these. Think about it for a moment.
If we negate this some x,
what does it mean not for some x.
X is a person that's
no people or no person.
If we negate this universal quantifier
over here, what does that mean?
Not all x where x is a person.
Consider the difference.
If there is not some eggs,
then there is no x.
If there is not all ex,
we're still left with some ex.
Take another example to be clear on this,
something is a turtle versus
everything is a turtle.
If I negate the first one I get,
nothing is a turtle.
If I negate the second one I get not
everything is a turtle before you take one
of fires and run with them.
Consider how we'd been using variables
with quantifiers instead of translating
all languages this way
we'll say for all x,
x is a language.
Same Way with the existential quantify
the logic for some fish is given some x,
x is a fish.
This is how you will use predicates and
variables to lay out logical sentences.
Let's look at how to render
more general terms in logic.
When we have words like someone somewhere,
some thing and the like,
the existential quantify or comes
into play. Someone is for some x,
x is human,
some thing is for some x or if you're
trying to bring out it's thingness given
some x, x is a thing. With that in mind,
what's everybody and everything in logic?
Take a moment to think about it.
Okay. If your answers you see universal
quantifier, congratulations. If not,
don't despair.
There are many more examples to come.
This gives you some perspective
on the scope of a quantifier.
Variables have a predicate,
are bound by a quantify or to their left.
The nearest applicable quantify or to be
precise acts is bound by quantify or on
x,
y by a quantifier on why?
In the proposition for all x x,
Y,
x is bound by the universal quantifier,
but why is free on the other hand?
Both X and y are bound in for all x.
There exists some y where x sees.
Why.
Notice that the predicate xcs why falls
within the scope of these quantifiers.
The variables x and y are also
bound in the following cases for x.
X is red,
and given y x sees why
in that second example,
why is bound, but x is free. Why
would you want to bind variables?
This is crucial to your logic.
Picture it this way.
The variables is like a blank space.
John saw Blake.
If you bind the variable,
you can form a sentence in a language.
John saw something,
otherwise you're leaving the blank space.
They're binding requires more work,
but it's crucial to logical thinking
and modeling real sentences, logic.
Now let's get to some translations
before we bring this lesson to a close.
Do your best to come up
with the following in logic.
Okay,
and there you have it. Next time we'll
take a look at logical operators,
which will add some flesh to the
bones of your logic skill on it.